avec valérie pécresse engageons nous
pour une écologie des résultats pour une
france des regards bonne nous déciderons
d'un plan de relance gaullien du
nucléaire avec la construction de 6e b r
nous développerons les énergies
renouvelables nous renforcerons les
aides aux ménages pour changer leurs
véhicules pollueurs pour une croissance
verte et durable sans gaspille une
lanceront un grand plan de rénovation
énergétique des logements et des
bâtiments publics
mettront en place une véritable taxe
carbone aux frontières pour protéger nos
emplois et notre agriculture 100% des
cantines publiques seront approvisionnés
en produits locaux et bio enfin nous
créerons un chèque récupération de 10
euros recycler les téléphones et de 50
euros pour les ordinateurs pour protéger
la nature et agir pour le bien-être
animal nous créerons une réserve
écologique citoyenne pour nettoyer nos
espaces naturels souillés ou en cas de
catastrophe écologique nous éradiqueront
les 100000 décharges sauvages grâce à la
vidéoprotection et au triplement des
sanctions nous créerons entiché dédié
des personnes condamnées maltraitance
animale enfin nous créerons un sombre un
label ville amie des animaux